the european parliament is still coming
to terms with the implications of the
u.s buying scandal for the eu
meps have discussed the suspension of
the swift proposal sealed in 2010.
swift gives the american authorities
conditional access to banking data in
order to track down terrorist financing
but the u.s national security agency
hasn't respected the safeguards
established by the eu and if we would
accept
this by
saying we leave the agreement as it is
but accept that it's circumvented all
other third states would question why
should we follow the agreements we have
with the european union we cannot accept
that we have to suspend the agreement
unless the usa is stopping these spying
activities
over 2 million syrians have fled their
war-torn country
large numbers have taken refuge in camps
in jordan turkey and some in iraq but
few have applied to come to europe just
fifty thousand meps want to increase aid
for syria's neighboring countries and
push member states to accept more syrian
refugees
the conflict
is
senegal's president has addressed
parliament urging europe to invest more
in africa especially in the sahel an
area destabilized by terrorism and
traffickers of all kinds the president
of senegal has also paved the way for
cooperation between africa and the 28 eu
member states laxative energy
the modernization the agriculture
the development the self-restrictive
education
law formation
alarm production